The One Piece Manga Just Revealed something
about the world of One Piece and its history
that will change how we see the story forever.
Because as it turns out, Egghead island the
Island with the most insane technology on
the entire planet, is not the island of the
future after all.
Instead, Vegapunk explains that his research
lab is actually a place of the past.
His technology pales in comparison to the
technically advancements made by the legendary
ancient kingdom, that was destroyed during
the void century.
And we see Luffy discovering what seems to
be a gigantic ancient robot outside the lab.
And there are 5 incredibly important things
that we can take away from this.
Like the fact that we now know for certain
that One Piece is a story taking place in
a post-apocalyptical world.
Which is absolutely crazy.
But where did Oda get the idea for this?
This reveal felt a lot like the one in Attack
on Titan, where you get fed one narrow perspective
on what the world is like, until you find
out nothing is what it seems.
That’s the exact same feeling here.
Turns out the world of one piece, as we know
it, is the cataclysmic aftermath of an era
of greatness before.
The first thing that came to my mind here
is the wheel of time.
In case you are not familiar with the story,
it’s a fantasy novel that takes place in
a medieval, lord of the rings-like world,
in the 3rd age after the breaking of the world.
Even though it is not a major plot point,
throughout the story the author feeds the
reader hints, that the world before this breaking
was actually our own reality.
That humanity became incredibly advanced in
the future and ultimately destroyed itself.
Leading to a complete setback and a world
that feels like fantasy.
That’s exactly the vibes i’m getting from
all this.
i can’t even begin to tell you how great
a piece of writing this is.
It makes the lore and story of one piece even
better than it already was.
The love Oda has for aliens and sci fi stories
like star wars are also gotten really apparent
in recent events.
And the giant mossy robot from a lost civilization
has pretty strong ‘castle in the sky vibes’
a gihbli movie that seems to have a number
of connections with one piece.
Go watch it if you haven’t.
It’s fantastic.
But it’s not only fiction that Oda was inspired
by.
Because there are multiple theories out there,
that our own world experienced such a set-back
as well.
People like Graham Hancock or Randal Carlson
argue that the last ice age started and ended
with a cataclysmic catastrophe that might
have wiped an already advanced ancient civilsation
from the face of the planet, roughly 12.000
years ago, lost as the sea levels rose over
80 meters in the aftermath.
It was this ancient civilization that built
the pyramids all around the world and mapped
the entire planet.
Now, I’m neither an archeologist nor a geologist,
so I can’t evaluate how accurate this is,
though there seems to be increasing evidence
for it.
In any case, it doesn’t matter for us here.
It’s an incredibly fun and interesting topic
to go down the rabbit hole for and due to
all the similarities these theories have with
Oda’s writing, I am 99% convinced that he
took inspiration from this idea.
Which brings be to the second point on my
list: What does this major reveal mean for
the one piece world and the context of the
story?
There used to be modern day technology on
the planet, including space travel and advanced
computing.
But at some point this advanced civilization
got defeated by the 20 kingdoms that later
became the world government that is ruling
the world today.
After this war.
a major technological setback happened, throwing
the world back into the age of guns and swords
and sea-faring.
It also explains why the world government
was so keen on wiping any trace of this kingdom
from the history books: If someone were to
find out the truth about their advanced civilization,
they would try and find and revive its technology
and use it against them.
Imu and the government are purposefully withholding
this knowledge and banning any research on
it, to keep their subjects unaware and incapable
of standing up against their tyrannical rule.
Now you might be wondering why that is such
a big deal.
After all there were many hints already in
the story that the ancient kingdom was quite
powerful.
So what has changed?
It’s the fact that what Luffy finds is a
giant functioning titanic robot.
We kind of assumed that much in the one piece
world is basically based on the stories own
magic system.
Devil fruits have a literal devil in them,
the ancient weapons are just unique abilities
certain people have and the ancient kingdom
built big cities, like wano and shandora and
were a place where everyone could live together
in harmony.
Technology wise maybe on the level of Ancient
Greece or something like that if you like.
But with the reveal that all of the fantastic
technology that Oda has shown us in vegapunks
lab so far, that all of that is not even on
the same level as the ancient kingdom used
to be, it tells us, that we are talking star
wars civilization level instead of ancient
rome.
That’s absolutely insane.
It means that the entire power system in One
PIece might very well be science.
After all science that is advanced enough
does look like magic if you’re unfamiliar
with it.
It means that devil fruits could be a technology
and not some sort of power system.
it also means, that the ancient weapons, to
me at least, suddenly become a much more terrifying
and graspable threat as well.
Think about something like the death star.
I explained how much Oda loves Star wars in
the last chapter review, where he introduced
light saber technology.
Pluton being buried in the volcano under wano
could be some apocalyptic giant machine with
unfathomable powers.
i think the idea that it’s futuristic war
tech, makes it so much more fascinating and
terrifying.
No wonder than maybe, that Roger was laughing
when he learned the true history.
About a time when you could fly to the moon,
heal all diseases and change the face of the
planet itself.
Joy boy most likely explained how all that
knowledge and technology would one day come
back, once the right conditions are met.
no wonder that Roger wished he was born in
the same era as Joy Boy.
And no wonder he and his crew were too early.
The knowledge and skills of this advanced
civilization were lost and would only return
at a certain point in the future.
It of course also explains why the world government
and Imu have technology no one else has.
Like the ability to eradicate an entire island.
They got their hands on the pieces of technology
that they wanted to secure their rule.
Which begs the third question: How in the
world did a kingdom with this level of knowledge
crumble in the first place?
The only thing we know for a fact about the
end of the void century, is that 20 countries
gathered together to defeat the ancient kingdom.
These countries would later on become the
celestial dragons, who are secretly being
ruled by the mysterious Imu.
But if Joy Boy and co were as powerful as
they seemed to have been, how did they lose?
One explanation is, that just like any other
empire in history, no matter how long it lasts,
at some point it starts falling apart from
inside, like Numenor in Lord of the rings.
A country that’s so wealthy and comfortable
in their position, that they start having
infighting and corruption gnawing away at
its former glory.
Maybe Imu and the 20 kings were actually allied
with or part of the ancient kingdom and backstabbed
Joy Boy.
Another option, is that the kingdom wasn’t
the only country with advanced technology.
Maybe the war was a conflict like we know
if from star wars, where boths sides have
access to terrible and advanced weapons.
Or, there is the wheel of time option, where
the civilsation becomes so advanced that they
discover something they shouldn’t have.
An external force, even greater than them,
Maybe the devil or devil fruit technology
was the thing that allowed the government
to wage war on the kingdom.
A new power ot match joy boy’s.
This would be a great explanation for Imu,
someone who offered the celestial dragons
his help, while secretly taking the throne
for himself, ruling from the shadows, where
he is able to still rely on his own ancient
technology, like the one that destroyed God
Valley and Lulusia.
Which means that for item 4 on our list, we
have to talk about all the things in the one
piece world that have hinted at technology
capable of shaping an entire planet.
Like the actual one piece planet itself.
Anyone who has seen the layout of the globe
knows, that the world of one piece feels incredibly
artificial.
the Grandline and Red line meet at a perfect
90 degree angle, and thus split the world
of one piece into 4 equally sized regions,
overlooked by the ruling celestial dragons
on top of the only continent in existence.
The red line is impossible to cross, since
flying technology is actively kept from emerging,
while the grand line, with its dangerious
and unpredictable weather and currents and
the windless calm belt around it guarded by
the sea kings, make it impossible to cross
by ship.
The rest of the world seems to be flooded,
so that the only inhabitable place are islands.
This results in a population that can’t
form larger groups or travel and learn about
the world.
Which of course is designed to keep people
from rising up against the government or learn
about things the government doesn’t want
them to learn about.
All the weird anomalies, like the existence
of sky islands or the giant hole under enies
lobby.
We originally thought that it might have been
devil fruits who shaped the world in this
way.
But now that we know just how advanced the
ancient kingdom really was, it seems much
more likely that actual technology or weapons
were used to terraform the planet into a place
that is easy to rule and control.
Think of Enel and his findings on the moon.
The fact that he found the plans for an actual
spaceship in Shandora and that he encountered
space pirates were always odd.
But now all these things are suddenly closely
tied to the void century.
There is technology and an army of robots
on the moon powered by electricity.
We have the giant arc noah, a ship big enough
to carry an entire civilization, waiting to
be used again.
And as we know, the technology in one piece
is all over the place: You have space ships
and lazer technology, while most people seem
to be stuck in the 17 hundreds, fighting with
swords and canons.
Modern steel warships, while most people sail
on wooden ones.
Video live streaming, while the rest of the
world is stuck with paper.
And curiously enough, all this advanced technology
seems to be Monopolized by one faction.
So for number 5 on the list, we have to ask
ourselves: What does this reveal mean for
Vegapunk and the government?
One thing that the story so far, and the egghead
island arc in particular has made clear, is
that Dr. Vegapunk doesn’t think very highly
of himself.
He describes momo’s devil fruit as a failure
and is clearly not very impressed with his
own work, calling it a place of the past.
Now I don’t think anyone who can build the
things he has built can be called anything,
but a genius, but it seems llke Vegapunk has
been reverse engineering a lot of the major
inventions he is credited with from technology
from the void century, something that seems
to bother him.
He seems disappointed that he can’t do what
the people 800 years ago were capable off.
Even though Momo’s fruit is a perfect copy
of Kaido’s, it’s just that, a copy.
Not an actual new devil fruit.
Based on the winged robots seen on the moon
by enel, it seems like the seraphim and pacifista
were also based on ancient technology.
They are based on research he conducted on
Kuma and King, who both seem to be lunarians,
who were known as the gods who lived on the
red line, possibly the original people of
the ancient kingdom.
The giant robots Vegapunk has seem to be based
on the giant one Luffy has just found.
In other words, all the crazy stuff vegapunk
has built is just a fraction of what used
to exist before.
It is also no surprise then, that the government
wants to take him out.
It seems like he might know more about the
true history and its power than almost anyone
else, making him the number one threat to
the government.
Rightfully so it seems, as one of the 6 Vegapunks,
shaka, is in contact with Dragon of the revolutionary
army.
By the way if you are a bit confused by the
entire 6 Vegapunk thing, how it works and
what each of them is like, I did a breakdown
of them in this video right here, that you
can watch next.